[Music]
welcome back
to another amazing episode of the hot
seat where we've got the hottest and
even hotter questions featuring
yoshi y'all
[Applause]
so you know you're in the hot seat we
want to get to know you but before we
get too hot out here because it gets
really steamy oh it's not really really
cold and dry and the master of that mr
bart quran
okay he's going to start it up
so scary yoshi yes
what's
your favorite
two-dimensional shape
two-dimensional
shape he's so good
he just says one word and then he goes
whatever follows it i'm gonna say it
he's prompting himself
he's mad listen waifu boobies wife with
boobies waifu boobies
oh the w
waifu
yeah god none of you are nervous jesus
that is what the hell is the wife that's
like that's um anime waifu
say that all the time
it's like a wife but you're saying it
like
oh like japanese anime style when i
google waifu boobies it shows up oh yeah
you said 2d right is that hentai oh
wait that's 2d that's 3d yeah
there's some real titties that's doubled
yeah that's 2d right i still [ __ ] with
the animators they're doing real hard
work out there trying hard hardest to
make good titties
[Laughter]
the real hardest to do good titties yeah
i feel like he was looking for like
triangle yeah that's what i was thinking
like a circle well he's trying to throw
me off i'm gonna throw him up like
that's a good answer i think that's a
good answer i think that's it
playstation one laura croft titties is
that what you're going for no that's 3d
that's polygon right we're not gonna do
that
maybe it's a big butt now because
everything's butt world not a big buck
ma'am cannot lie all right well between
questions we always have them shed one
article of clothing so then just take
that off we'll get started we'll just
take it off and then we'll get going
oh he's not he's a tease he knows this
game he's a sneak attacker we tried to
do some fan service but no
i guess i guess we have a christian
today
congrats i'm being born again i've been
sitting here drinking the whole time i'm
like
[Laughter]
that's amazing you got one of those baby
belt alien ballers that's his talent
here we go
let's say what's your favorite color
chainsaw
black old black
right along the blade you got to watch
the show in order let's say
let's say you're a mormon for lucifer
how do you sell that religion dude what
good i'm a mormon for luke yeah you're
on a bicycle and you're like saying you
got your little short sleeves yeah get
your state and then get your satan today
first i would unbutton a few okay right
because we're we're selling lucifer oh
cause it's hot
but he's not yeah
to break the law
no but then you don't have the helmet
because you got to have the hair like
you know you take it off
yeah halfway through halfway through so
you're losing them a little bit you take
it off and you're like cool
yeah you're lustful okay i mean lucy
you grew up in california yes i did
your name is yoshi it is yoshi well like
in school because of the mario games
well
that's actually
why i got the name yoshi my real name is
joshua and people can say it properly
yoshua yeah does your mom mess up it's
just like joshua so it's exactly that's
right in indonesia
like we go by hebrew style it's not
joshua joshua becomes yosua or yeshua
and so when we moved here they added the
h but they didn't change the y to a j
got it why do you guys go hebrew style
they're original they go to the source
they're like [ __ ] that [ __ ] anglo
[ __ ]
yeah hebrew national francs
that's the third question actually is
that the most popular hot dog yeah
that's really up there
i thought actually i don't know maybe
maybe at first i thought you were
japanese
i know because your name yeah i remember
you're like yoshi oh you're japanese too
that's cool and you're like wait i'm
like a little bit yo she's not japanese
and then it's like a nickname right yeah
so i was like how come peter doesn't
have a japanese name yeah and it's my
older brother's christian peter
peter that was that's what that was our
real name oh that makes sense and then
peter peter from saint peter saint peter
that's right yeah man would you want to
be when you grew up when your kid
i wanted to be a fire truck driver like
oh you wanted to be on youtube i don't
know why i said fire truck driver all
right that's fine now you can identify
as one if you want you just want to
drive the truck but hey guys put that
out please listen listen
the reason why i lit the fire truck
is because my kid loves trucks right now
and all he does is point out trucks so
when i let's say fireman
i said fire truck because i've been used
to like acknowledging the truck existed
scott's so much
[Music]
here take these they're for free here
here's some food
so you have a kid that's okay that's
obviously a big step what made you and
your and your wife go like okay it's
time to just settle down let's do this
or was it that was always the plan uh we
had already thought about that and it
was just like
we're never going to be ready so we just
you guys were uh high school sweethearts
right
we weren't high school sweethearts but i
i liked her when i moved to america when
i was eight i saw her
and i loved her like that was like i was
like her like she was like a [ __ ]
girl across the street like winnie
winnie it was a church no way so you
love whatever you were saying
yeah as much as a kid could love
somebody else i was like mom i'm going
to marry her and my mom was like okay
chilly wow when you were eight did you
guys ever have a rough part of the
relationship have a break and then you
like screwed a bunch of [ __ ] yeah you
[ __ ] a ton of [ __ ] yo wow
it's a hot seat right i don't know no i
did not no i did not okay no i'm just i
i nick was asking me to ask you yeah
anthony have a moment in time when i was
gonna ask because i i knew if i was
gonna start dating her we started
getting to know each other like around
my 20s
and i knew if i asked her out that was
it she was going to be the only because
you guys are like old-school like church
buddies so that style is like when you
date
it's like almost marriage it wasn't so
much that because i wasn't necessarily
being super like christian boy or
whatever but i just knew i was like
there
isn't anyone like her and i had already
kind of like known it in my head that i
was being friends for so long we became
friends uh we knew each other like from
eight years old to like 20 but we didn't
like
interact as friends we knew each other
we saw each other at church and she
would serve and i would surf but it
wasn't always like oh my god it's her
yes it was every weekend how did she see
you then at 7 35 we turn up the heat a
little bit
if you were to put two pictures right
yes same lady your wife
one when she's eight one now which one's
hotter
because you fell in love when you were
eight that's what you said you said
something you are now like you're not as
young as you used to look like you're
all you're so old now that's a very
you're a [ __ ] aging yeah he actually
is probably one of the rare few that
can't answer that yeah it was yeah you
guys were like i liked it when i first
met you but like uh 7 35 minutes not the
same woman that i knew got hotter every
year
and i'm happy with it
that's good that's good you handle that
you gotta take
that's that's super interesting to me
like um you know like like it's it's not
that
common where at least for me where you
find your your your first crush yeah and
then you basically stay in contact with
this crush
because usually people like move away or
whatever right and then you stay in like
friends or whatever and then you
actually
get to be with her
i remember the moment because i was i
dated somebody else in high school and
because i i stopped going to that
the church that sarah and i grew up in
like uh i only went on sundays and i
barely saw her instead of going on to
like the youth group so i started dating
somebody else and i remember at the tail
end of our relationship we ended it um
my high school like girlfriend at the
time and out of nowhere it's like she
like knew she didn't know that i was not
dating or dating anyone or whatever but
she saw me and she was like oh you look
really nice today like you know han
touching would you like and i praise the
lord bro i went to peter straight away
and i was like i think i still love
sarah
he was like no
but that was kind of the start of it all
oh this is while you're dating the other
no no we had we had broken up but but i
told you trying to catch him yeah
watch it watch it now
but but between uh my
high school girlfriend and her i did i
did date other women and i was like you
know what i'm just gonna go a little
crazy like you said i went a little
crazy and then i it was like straight up
i feel like his version of little crazy
is still very gentlemanly
like going to the movies
rated pg-13
she's really clean on the streets yeah
usually means a freak in the sheets
this was college yeah yeah yeah it was
it went a little crazy where i like get
a little crazy failed classes
failed classes it's self-discovery you
know i i pushed back like a couple
semesters because of it yeah it was it
was yeah i i went a little too were you
did you go to long beach i did okay
because i think that's when i met you
lbs
you were a cheerleader yes oh we have a
lot of shirts
world champ baby so now we got too many
too many dancers
who the [ __ ] said too many dancers huh
earlier we actually we had chappelle
today he's a comedian
oh yeah
and cheerleader too yeah he's a stand-up
comedian and i was a former cheerleader
yeah we won worlds in 2011. what's
worlds
like nationals sorry
nationals in daytona so they did like a
big old what if he was here too and then
they were just like oh my god today's
video is brought to you by expressvpn
when did we decide to stop upholding
free speech as a basic human right
what's playing out right now at big tech
companies and social media sites sets a
dangerous precedent look it doesn't
matter what your politics are or who you
voted for everyone should have the right
to express themselves freely sadly the
big tech monopoly has instead opted for
silencing tactics and censorship to
fight back against big tech's control of
the internet i use expressvpn ever
wonder how free to access tech giants
make all their money well
by tracking your searches video history
and everything you click on by building
a profile on you and then selling off
your sensitive data when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity much more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers what's
more expressvpn
encrypts a hundred percent of your
network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals what i
like most is how easy it is to use it
just takes one click to protect all of
your devices that's why expressvpn is
rated number one by business insider
let's stop allowing big tech to revoke
our rights to free speech why not revoke
their right to your data instead secure
your internet with the vpn that i trust
for online protection visit
expressvpn.com off the record that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
off the record to get three extra months
free with my exclusive link go to
expressvpn.com
off the record right now to learn more
do you guys start fighting each other
they start lifting each other
our boy
[Laughter]
because we already heard about the the
bruising and the veneer and stuff like
that uh any other worst injuries from
stunts uh from cheer from cheer i i uh
fractured my l4 l5 oh [ __ ] yeah i was
trying to do the lifting stuff and i was
so skinny i was like 145 at my height
so you lifted uh something and then
you're
lifted a girl
whoa she's 300 pounds well he hasn't
done something i was i was throwing like
girls who were like 115 120 and it was
fine yeah but thank you
but they said
my dude is
but i threw a 90 pound girl and she
didn't know how to stay up there and
didn't know how to jump so she got up
and she didn't stay tight and she like
went like this and i went i was like oh
and i'm like oh that was weird but then
we had to keep rehearsing and i was like
20 20 years old i was like whatever so i
went and i was the jumper of our you
know in the beginning of the section so
i do my jumps and i throw
all these crazy jumps and then there's
this double toe touch that i do and on
the second toe touch my legs are up here
and the back just locks up and i go
straight down on my spine oh my god and
i went clap and i was like i can't move
why is chilling so [ __ ] scary dude
chilling was he telling me crazy stories
oh yeah but today i'm learning so much
[ __ ] about cheerleading that i'm like
dude that's a dangerous sport and the
thing is it's not considered a sport so
they don't get money and it shouldn't be
considered a sport but i'm still scared
of it
it there are some crazy [ __ ] because if
it's yours
cheers my next campaign with nike cheers
a sport
dude let's get started mike here he's
like cheering he's not a [ __ ] sport
he's not a [ __ ] sport
okay chill out
[Laughter]
but it's like you know b-boying finally
being considered a sport yeah olympic
sport you're like wait a minute silence
cheer is still not
isn't there competitive cheering like
events though that are just private and
and like they do the whole big shows
yeah absolutely but the problem is you
have to like shovel uh you have to bring
out all the money on your own versus the
schools taking care of it because it's
not considered a sport yeah what's the
uh
acting job that you're the most proud of
and what's the one that you
um if you could have it back yeah you
need to you could bury it yeah get rid
of it oh if i didn't have to i think
every experience that i've had so far
has led me to who i am so i'm okay with
everything even though if it was like
terrible
especially jk right because this was
your launch of your career right it's jk
that was the launch of it for sure the
most terrible one then jk terrible one
now jake you have the least fun now jk
that i had the least fun yeah
we were like we were like paramount
pictures back in the day nope
nope
you were like the original dude
and people forget about that [ __ ] that
was the thing he's like you son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you to like pull me in and
and do acting stuff yeah you guys are
like today's wong fu
yeah
definitely
nah i don't think so
anyway
[Laughter]
uh i mean i don't know like there are
some work like bad stuff that's happened
during sets and stuff like that but
i wouldn't say it ruined my whole
experience as the film but i did one uh
the western that i did in indonesia that
looks dope it was awesome it was so much
fun i got to play a [ __ ] cowboy which
you don't get
but it's really good they're not
super safe in a lot of stuff
so there was a scene and and uh the
dutch officer that was playing with me
he was very method
and i was like hey guys make sure that
the knife is a fake one before we get
going and i forget i'm doing makeup
and
i get there and we're doing the
rehearsal and i feel cold hard steel on
my neck
and i'm like whoa okay that's not the
fake one and i like cold cut and
everything and i'm tied up because he
was supposed to be like attacking me
and then i was like well all right nope
we're not doing that and i i go up to
the uh prop master and they're like i
was like bro fake knife the the prop
knife he was like oh it is it's not
sharp i was like
it's still pointy
i'm not letting that get to my neck
so then they finally like brought out
the you know fake one and and and then
the method guy got all mad because he
was good he grabbed the knife and he was
like what is this and he threw it like
right at me
it was a little crazy method x's are
wild and i was like bro i'm number one
on this i'm gonna get you fired
but i it was my first time being number
one so i didn't want to like i didn't
know how to that i could do that you
know what do you think of method actors
though
well here's the thing people are talking
about this right now yes they are and
and
method acting as long as it doesn't to
me as long as it doesn't um
inconvenience other people and and and
screw with other people and it's not a
way for you to
uh be shitty to people shitty things and
and get away with it doesn't extend into
other people's shoes yeah i like baldwin
method acting with the [ __ ] bullet
i don't understand that because he fired
it
at the director and
and and the dp which is at camera if
they were standing at camera there
shouldn't have been anyone there anyway
if he was pointing at it so i don't
think he was supposed to even fire them
and there was a screen cap and his
finger was on the trigger really yeah
yeah he's supposed to have a trigger
discipline yeah but like it is in his
testimony so my finger was never on the
trigger whatever and then like and it
fired without that yeah there's an image
that was uh released and his finger was
on oh yeah fully well if he shot
somebody so even so on set even if it's
like if it's fake gun no ammo you still
don't point it directly at people ever
so actually that's the other funny thing
my
best and favorite job that i've ever had
was the job that i just did in atlanta i
got to play uh uh just a dude i as much
as i love like asian rep and and like
talking about our cultural stuff
i got i want stories of asian people who
are just in stories right and so in this
last movie that i did i was the number
one first number one in a us film
and it's a romance film and i'm just a
dude it was really quick you're talking
about on the call sheet on the call
sheet yeah so just for people yeah yeah
the lead role of it and
i it they don't like go into why i'm
asian i just i am and it's yeah we don't
all have to have a movie called like
tears of a [ __ ] soy sauce or
something right we can have both we can
have both those are really good we can
have both academy awards that's right
that's why rufio was so like valuable
he's just
like oh they stole this kid from china
now
he was he was just they stole this
[ __ ] badass
asian dude yeah
but asians do that [ __ ] too though like
they create films that are just like
[ __ ] chopstick drama or some [ __ ]
like it's gotta be like come on
just make a [ __ ] story about
gymnastics or some [ __ ] and
the thing is there's space for both sure
this is what i'm trying to say asian
sensation it's okay oh that's cool
that's cool right i'm down with asian
invasion yeah
but it's asian sensation i don't know an
aggression you remember this in the
little gangster never
that's so loud the gymnastics movie is
called
that quan i'm gonna make that movie i'm
i will be i will be quan
i'm down like your most recent project
it was like it was a romance film and
sex
did you have a sex scene he method acted
with another woman that was it it wasn't
it wasn't like it's a white chick
otherwise
i had i had three different love
interests kind of crazy of course you
would yoshi
method acting they were very they were
very like good about making me feel
comfortable and and i i hope i was able
to do the same for them and we had like
a a a coach for all of that like all the
scenes so it was all good intimacy is
there a scene where the girl says kiss
me and not cause you're asian
there he is
i wrote that in
so cringe
that's so cringe
so crazy i love it
kiss me he's like on my screen on the
take that you do for yourself like
directional whatever you want kiss me
affirmative action it's not because i'm
first generation american but from
indonesian roots right
so it's good writing but it's also my
very first like indonesian character in
the us
but the funny thing is like
how many times you say mi goreng
once or
twice the funny thing is because of the
whole gun thing with like baldwin we had
a scene where there was a gun that had
to be pointed at me
and and you know they were like we have
the prop gun that is metal and we have
one that is plastic we don't need the
blowback because it wasn't a blowback
gun um so we'll just use the plastic for
this you know is that okay for everybody
i was like yeah that's fine
and they're like we're gonna check it
we're showing it to everyone blah blah
blah and i was like anybody who wants to
check it go ahead and check it so i'll
go check it because it's being pointed
at me and i get to be the last one to
there was a bullet in there
it's like the spring one you know you
can tell like the feel of it and all
that stuff
but when you're doing that right you
don't want to laser anyone lasering is
like when you point it at anybody's face
you keep it to the ground while you're
checking making sure
but because of the whole i think i like
multiple things everybody was like i
want to check it i want to check it
everybody's checking it and they're
going like this they're grabbing it and
they're doing this
they're at my face
[Laughter]
i was like okay i get wanting to check
it but if you don't know what you're
doing
don't guys that don't know how to [ __ ]
with guns they'll do [ __ ] like this is
it is it loaded i was dying dude imagine
if they had to check nunchucks and each
person got to do a run
oh my god there's a bullet in here hey
you want to check these chucks yeah
dude you want to feel safe my uncle was
a sheriff
actual [ __ ] san diego county sheriff
he's sitting there cleaning a gun
pointing at my [ __ ] dad's head the
whole time so yeah my dad's like what
the [ __ ] you doing craig
a real gun what the [ __ ] chuck who gives
a [ __ ]
[Applause]
go watch it when it's out
you